pour intégrer cet abattoir donc j'ai
postulé à une offre qui était sur pôle
emploi pour travailler au sein des
services vétérinaires de l'abattoir
bigard de cuiseaux et j'ai envoyé un cv
avec un baccalauréat et 3 expérience
dans l'industrie qui n'avaient rien à
voir accessible de postes d'accord j'ai
rapidement eu un entretien avec le
vétérinaire officiel de l'abattoir est
en fait c'est vite devenu présentation
de postes j'ai vite compris qu'ils
avaient il n'y avait pas d'autre
candidat en fait élever tonnerre mais la
poussera met d'accord vous étiez le seul
candidat gt gt le seul candidat d'accord
donc ima on n'a pas vraiment eu
d'entretien il m'a montré la chaîne
d'abattage et me montrer à mon futur
poste et à la fin il m'a demandé alors à
ce que tu as peur du couteau est ce que
tu as peur du sang est en fait là j'ai
compris que c'était un des seuls
critères de d'embûches pour pouvoir
intégrer les services vétérinaires de
l'abattoir d'accord alors on va voir
première image
c'est une image qui a énormément fait
parler cette vidéo où l'on découvre que
le sont des veaux morts est prélevée
dans l'institut dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
regardez ça
avant d'être jetés dans les poubelles il
ya une personne qui en charge de
récupérer de prélever le sang de ces
foetus aux enfers du sérum le
prélèvement de sang et fait surtout
utile de foetus mais principalement sur
sur les foetus prête à naître puisque
c'est là qu'on trouve la plus grosse
quantité de sang à partir du sang
ponctionnés sur les foetus en opérateur
de l'abattoir va extraire du ceram qui
sera commercialisée par serra france et
qui sera vendu aux industries
pharmaceutiques pour faire de la culture
cellulaire rendez vous
chabbert
vous avez une caméra sur vous à chaque
fois quand même caméra cachée comme ça
vous étiez en immersion comment s'est
passé alors je peux pas vous donner les
détails techniques pour réaliser ces
images me rassure bien sûr mais c'est
vous qui avez tout filmé c'est moi qui
étais aussi mis d'accord alors quand
vous voyez ça est-ce qu'il y en a qui se
disent pas ce que je vous dit où on va
on se dit tous ici à thomas il ya des
gens aussi on va avoir d'autres images
et des gens qui disent aussi c'est des
milliers d'emplois et
ccc aussi voilà c'est ça ça va mettre
beaucoup de gens au chômage si elle
passe cette industrie voiliers de
travail par voilà c'est vrai que voilà
je vous dis toujours je vous dis tout ce
que je vois sur les réseaux sociaux il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont bien sûr
très choqué la plupart par ces images il
y en a aussi qui disent ah qu'est ce que
vous dites à ces gens là non mais
évidemment que c'est on va pas aller on
va pas fermer les abattoirs parce que
malheureusement on n'a pas les moyens de
fermer les abattoirs en revanche faire
un coup de balai nettoyer essayer de le
faire parce que aidé à battre de façon à
ce que les animaux souffrent le moins
possible est bon et le moins de 2 de
latence est ce que conscience et la loi
voilà ce qui est ce qui est normalement
la loi moi ce qui me sidère c'est bon je
vois monsieur que vous avez envoyé un cv
avec aucune qualification quand vous
demande rien ce n'est ce que vous avez
peur du sang et d'un couteau et
qu'ensuite on vous jette là dedans en
vous disant en gros démerde toi c'est ça
qui est incroyable ça en plus de ça donc
je n'avais pas de pas de diplôme pas
d'expérience et j'ai eu aucune formation
donc en fait j'ai et on a donné des
explications sur le tas à des
informations contradictoires et s a eu
des conséquences je pense assez grave à
la fois sur le point de vue sanitaire et
sur le bien-être animal alors par
exemple on me disait quand tu trouves
des scolioses sur la carcasse a battu tu
dois les enlever une cité reste
quelques-unes ses pattes arriver
quelqu'un derrière va s'en charger
d'autres me disais non non il faut qu'il
faut que les enlève les que tu sortes la
carcasse mais en fait les foulures c'est
entre l'herbe fraîche la matière fécale
est resté combien de temps je suis resté
quatre mois et donc dans les fouilleurs
en fait liée à la bactérie escherichia
coli est dangereuse pour la santé
humaine c'est extrêmement grave et sa
mort m'a jamais dit mais en fait si si
les consommateurs mangent cette bactérie
l'aï leopard et ils peuvent mourir ça
c'est extrêmement dangereux on n'a
jamais informé de ça et c'est pareil
pour le bien-être animal en fait j'ai
marché dont je voudrais qu'on montre un
autre extrait bien sûr qu'il nous a
glacé le sang celui où l'on découvre
l'abattage rituel
c'est une étape que vous avez pu
contrôler au bout d'une semaine après
avoir été embauché sarthe a fait donc
une semaine après vous étiez à s'auto
elle va même dans laquelle vous assistez
à l'égorgement des vaches sans
anesthésie regardez ces images sont c
est forte
elle mal rentrer dans une box c'est
entendu eu de pillage cylindrique pour
faire entrer une vache dans le piège
abattages rituels il faut la forcer ils
ne rendent pas d'elle-même donc on lui
met des coups de bâton des coûts de
piles électriques parfois même souvent
j'ai même déjà vu une personne met des
coups de bâton exprimant dans le
visionnage pour qu'elle sorte la tête de
l'eau dans le cadre de l'abattage rituel
lorsqu'il ya des signes évocateurs d'une
prise de conscience des opérateurs de
l'abattoir sont censés étourdir
d'urgence l'animal pour lui éviter des
souffrances inutiles en quatre mois dans
cet abattoir pendant toute ma mission je
n'ai jamais assisté à des scènes
d'étourdissement d'urgence